it's a celebration it's it's a great day
for the seattle seahawks who still may
end up being the number one seed it's a
great day here we're still in the
holiday festive mood
or maybe not but hey regardless it's
that you know this is that week between
christmas and new year's where
what there's a different vibe right
and the season
culmination is awaiting and the playoffs
are coming this is a fun time for the
nfl isn't it
it isn't it is a fun time for the nfl i
mean i don't know i i was waiting for
you to go somewhere
negative there for a second but okay i'm
gonna do it all right good you're not
gonna do it all right good no but it is
a very fun time good i'm glad that
you're happy very good happy holidays
uh superlatives time coming out of week
16 and there are plenty of different
things because actually for the second
straight week
i spent time last night thinking of
superlatives instead of just doing them
on the fly so i feel pretty good about
my superlatives as always though i'll
let you do the honor oh go first yeah go
ahead all right uh well and and this one
is is fairly simple and fairly obvious
but at the top of the hour we need to at
least play the hits the better late than
never award goes to the pittsburgh
steelers the pittsburgh steelers had
fallen and they couldn't get up and
somehow some way with the season
crumbling around them with the prospect
although with the browns failing to win
in new york the steelers were still
going to win the division yesterday even
with a loss i don't know that they would
have had the same party with the hats
and the t-shirts in the locker room if
they had been trounced by the colts and
then the browns lose to the jets but
they were still going to win the
division the way things played out for
the browns but the idea that three
straight losses
offense had gone awol no one has any
answers they spot the colts a 24-7 lead
in the third quarter the offense fails
to convert on fourth and goal from the
two and there was just that vibe as
we're watching all the games in the one
o'clock window that was the moment where
it's like all right i'm done with that
one and i start focus on a different one
and that was the moment they finally
woke up that's what it took and and they
get the win what it means going forward
i don't know but when you look at the
extent of the celebration that came out
of that locker room if this wasn't just
a celebration of winning the division
this was a celebration of getting out of
this this quicksand that they tripped
into against washington three weeks ago
and avoiding what would have been a
potentially epic collapse to win 11
games to start the season and
potentially lose five in a row to end
the season even if you're in the
playoffs that's something no one wants
to be attached to chris no definitely
not i mean it's just no way to go into
the playoffs i mean you're you're beaten
down at that point you know that that
win yesterday for them was so big in so
many ways you know we they were feeling
the pressure they have not played well
maybe that righted the ship certainly
given them some confidence to go hey we
got our mojo back
and i think in all seriousness too
because you brought this up in the first
hour and i think this is very real
is
their their their their covid 19
schedule
it really screwed them up i mean i don't
know what else to say you can literally
look at a direct correlation from when
that all happened and rescheduling games
to
they got worse right there for a number
of weeks and i do think that stressed
them out threw them off kilter whatever
you want to say but either way that was
uh great by them in the second half uh
and looked like it was bad even you know
halfway through the second half there
but they gotta go and and that was uh
quite quite impressive uh for for them
to get it going like that um all right
and the point the point we made last
hour too and let's reiterate it here
right they have to decide what they're
going to do this weekend against the
browns the browns trying to get into the
postseason and as i said last hour in
relation to the bills and the dolphins
if you have an opportunity to knock out
a division rival that you don't want
rolling into your stadium for the first
round of the playoffs or the second
round or whenever knock him out if you
can do you try to keep the saw sharp now
that you've finally found a way to win
or do you shut it down and give the guys
the bye week that they never got
because of the covet 19 messed up
steelers schedule yeah i i mean it's
it's a really good discussion
and
i think if i'm the pittsburgh steelers
i err on more on
rest than anything
i do you know i know we talked about it
in the first hour the offense just got
it going i'd like to see them go out
there and at least you know execute
throw the ball around end the regular
season with a good taste in your mouth
going into the playoffs something like
that you know against the browns defense
that's not real good you know i think
the defense needs rest the offense is
going to be the tricky one how do they
feel about big ben his health where they
are as an offense do they feel like they
need that work the defense we know what
they are they're really damn good i do
think they're worn out and beaten down
to your point mike to where they do need
the rest
all right you ready me well we'll see
yeah we're i'm ready i i was i i was
gonna jump in but i'm just gonna let you
go with yours what's what's the what's
the opposite of like a four-leaf clover
like what like in all seriousness i'm
asking like what's bad luck a black cat
is that where we're at like black cat
would be a bad a broken mirror how about
the broken yeah right the four-leaf
clover versus the the broken mirror
award there because like we had like one
team the kansas city chiefs who have
like a four-leaf clover up their butt
all the time yeah i was one i think
you're talking about four-leaf clover
when your your typical articulation of
someone who is lucky is to say they have
a horseshoe up there but i'm glad that
that you added that to this well yeah
this is the the the chiefs are so lucky
they have a horseshoe and a clover up
their butt all right that's a double
whammy there they really are and three
rockets and then i don't know the
falcons are like they literally i think
we're holding a black cat in a mirror at
the same time and drop the mirror just
to make sure everything can be bad but
they're cursed i don't know what else to
say with them as a football team that
was not a good look for the kansas city
chiefs football team yesterday mahomes
and the offense never looked comfortable
it's amazing what they do it's still
amazing even in the 17-14 win it's just
whenever they needed the drive whether
that was the last drive of the football
game or the last drive of the first half
they do it it's unbelievable
but man are they playing with fire this
way and i i know i will bet that they
would come out on top more times than
not with this type of stuff but you know
for a week 16 showdown about a team we
look at is clearly the best in football
you know they haven't been playing their
best football as of late and they were
asleep at the wheel a little bit
yesterday and of course the falcons were
the falcons and found a way not to tie
the football game
but there's something about the chiefs i
know where they dance on that line and
and i asked travis kelsey about this
yesterday what feeling does he think is
stronger the feeling among the chiefs in
a situation like that that it's
inevitable or the feeling that you get
from the other sideline they're thinking
oh god here we go here come the chiefs
because you knew after the dropped
interception in the end zone by aj
tyrell you knew what was coming that's
right i knew what was coming that's what
i mean a p
i
dash missile from patrick mahomes and
that's lights out yes i i you're exactly
right but that's what i mean it's just
there were so many instances there of
you know
horseshoe up your butt and black cat
yesterday in the football game it was
unreal there was chances where the
falcons could have controlled the
football game could have really put the
chiefs in a bad spot they didn't
capitalize and you're right the chiefs
always capitalize they really do their
defense was phenomenal yesterday chris
jones was amazing he really was and yeah
my homes and company just got it done uh
but it wasn't pretty that's for sure and
you know i
i understand it too you know like we've
talked about they're a team that takes
everybody's best shot
and within the natural human emotions of
football and everything like that
they've played some big time football
games lately so you got the falcons
coming into town who are not that great
and yeah you beat the dolphins you beat
the saints on the road you beat the
bucks not long ago on the road too those
are three out of your last four wins
coming into yesterday so yeah they
caught them napping but they still win
they're amazing the chiefs that way they
really are that's that's what's
fascinating about it to me
even when you get them on a flat day
they still find a way and they found a
way every day
every sunday monday thursday whenever
other than the raiders game where it
took 40 points to kill the dragon they
they just keep winning and they just
keep winning and now you've got me
reflecting on all the various types of
superstitions that are out there because
my dad was
ridiculously superstitious the italians
i think there's a lot there's a lot of
superstitions i don't understand them
they're big on salt there's something
about salt you spill the salt but then
there's like a little bat like when i
got a car for the first time my dad put
a little bag of salt in my glove box and
i tried to i tried to tell him that if i
get pulled over they're going to think i
got a bag of cocaine
box
my first day of school my first day of
school
first grade 1971.
the the pocket on the shirt he popped it
open and he starts shaking salt i
thought he lost his mind he's shaking
salt in my pocket so the salt's a big
thing too so i didn't know that one i'm
gonna i didn't know i'm gonna go down
the rabbit hole of superstition research
as soon as the show is over because now
you've got me thinking about and
reflecting on all the various
superstitions that my dad had as a
result i have none i am not
superstitious at all i say it every time
there's a friday the 13th come and get
me i'm not afraid of you all right next
up um
i'm going to go back because i don't
want to get so caught up in what
happened on sunday
uh even though sunday was great i'm
going to take a broader view of week 16
since it was packed together in a couple
of days and my next one is the it must
be the shoes award because here comes
alvin kamara with a red shoe and a green
shoe on christmas day they didn't make
him take them off as they would have
made odo beckham jr take them off i have
tried to reconcile the nfl's approach
here
i'm told that the rules now only call
for directing the player to get rid of
non-conforming equipment if there's a
safety or a branding issue
otherwise they'll deal with it through
the normal disciplinary reasons so why
did it happen the other times that
that didn't stop them from telling otto
beckham
last year you got to take your shoes off
that's a collateral issue i know but
that's still very annoying and
hypocritical i know right i agree and i
made that point at pft thank you for
reading over the weekend but uh but alan
kamara i you know we have been waiting
and waiting and waiting and waiting i
thought reggie i thought reggie bush
would potentially do it i thought randy
moss would potentially do it a six
touchdown game
since december 1965 that had not
happened alvin kamara became only the
fourth player in nfl history to score
six touchdowns in one game it was
amazing it was uncanny and it had
something to do with the fact that the
vikings defense was absolute and total
crap but still there have been a lot of
crap defenses over the years but six
touchdowns unbelievable accomplishment
by alvin kamara and
yeah i i don't i don't think it does
enough to get him into the offensive
player of the year conversation when you
look at his numbers and compare them to
others but i i think that scoring six
touchdowns in one game
is is like extra credit right you always
look for an opportunity to get extra
credit so you could get your b to an a
or whatever the case may be in your case
the d to a c but but you're looking for
extra
nothing you're looking for extra credit
i think you get extra credit for scoring
six touchdowns in one game don't you
well
it's a phenomenal
performance it is he's a special
football player you know you could
certainly argue
he's the mvp of that offense or that
football team one of the best players in
the league but he just he had a few too
many games of
you know not great stat lines not great
statistics to be in that conversation
but either way like you know you and me
talking football he is in that
conversation we know that he's one of
the best offensive players in the game
you know he really is the way he can
carve you up in the run game pass game
for a guy that's not real big the the
physicality in which he can run make
people miss in space he's amazing he
really is and the saints you know
they're amazing too there they are off
of you know a tough loss last week
against the kansas city chiefs they come
back they don't blink an eye and they
just steamroll your minnesota vikings
just absolutely whoop their butt uh in
the run game everything like that uh
that was that was impressive to watch
almost 600 yards of total offense i mean
hey that was that was amazing
i'm well aware and uh i wrote something
about this over the weekend the past 20
years for minnesota vikings can be
characterized in three words just good
enough and they have gotten by dog
paddling through the waters of just good
enough never striving to be great other
than 2009 when they went all in for
brett favre and almost got to the super
bowl it's just good enough contend in
december get to the playoffs one year
don't get there the next year but always
be in it up until the very end that's
good for business see
they'll tell you and i mean every team
will tell you we want to win the super
bowl we want to win the super bowl well
if you use that as your barometer for
success you're going to be pissed off
all the time sorry london even the
patriots they've failed two out of three
times over the past 20 years to win the
super bowl
you're a failure if that's your standard
your standard is
be relevant as deep into the season as
possible in that regard the vikings are
wildly successful but but they're not
great they they're they're and they're
content to not be great chris and you're
not going to see any major changes
coming out of minnesota after this year
they're just going to retool reload and
just go ram their head into the wall all
over again they'll probably make it to
the playoffs next year which will
validate it and then the year after that
they won't that that's the cycle that
the vikings are on and i don't see it
ending anytime soon well you know i mean
i i i hear you i i don't think you're
that far off from being a
damn really good competitive football
team next year either so don't get your
hopes totally down here come on don't
jump off the viking ship completely
listen all right you know you know you
want to hang on a little bit
minnesota man this guy's really hanging
like you're like you're hanging on by a
rope that's hanging off the end of the
viking ship right now but you're still
holding up my son my son my son
is actually trying to do something that
i once tried to do years ago he's
actually trying to renounce and jump on
the bill's banner oh i like it i told
him i told him go ahead go ahead and try
go ahead and try so go ahead maybe
that's what you have to do maybe that's
what maybe that's what needs to happen
to end the curse
that's what happens
you leave kirk cousins and the vikings
who can you know the vikings this opher
super bowl team to go for another opher
super bowl team
and you break the curse maybe that's
what happens he goes with my boy blue
and just everything's good and then you
could stick with the fight and then the
vikings win the super bowl
is that what happens is it like the don
mattingly thing like didn't mattingly
retire one year too early
didn't he yeah isn't that it yeah and
they won the world series the next year
yes very sad either way i have these
weird random baseball facts that just
kind of pop out from time to time and i
have no confidence in them but i do
vaguely remember that all right uh
you're up uh
the uh oh award or yeah i just uh oh
they're looking scary
i wouldn't want to have to play them in
the playoffs and that will go to the
baltimore ravens because they're
starting to look scary here with what
we've seen over the last few weeks their
offense has got it going a little bit i
know it wasn't just a high-flying act
yesterday but they controlled the game
with the new york giants pretty early
and were able to kind of coast through
the finish line but the way the run game
and lamar jackson has looked we've seen
a little bit more involvement from wide
receivers in the passing game not that
it blows you away but it's enough to
where defense has got to think about it
and then the defense of the baltimore
ravens seems like it's getting a little
healthy here so this is what four games
in a row now we've seen from the
baltimore ravens all of them have been
pretty impressive on the offensive side
of the football that's for sure and the
defense has made plays when they've had
to but we're dominant yesterday really
dominant and uh we'll see but i i the
ravens are looking like one of those
teams right now where
you know i don't know man i wouldn't
want to have to see them in the wild
card round coming into town no matter
who you are lamar jackson those good
players that offensive line that
defensive line they'll be scary they'll
be tough to beat
hey and i think the one team that should
be ready to run and hide if the ravens
come back is the pittsburgh steelers
because i firmly believe that the ravens
are supremely confident that if they
would catch the steelers again after
being swept by pittsburgh the game that
remember back in week 8 the ravens
completely dominated that game
but the steelers found a way to win it
and then when they got together again
after the six day delay because of the
covetous break with the ravens they were
dramatically under
manned and they still almost won the
game if they would be at full strength
against pittsburgh i think they would
beat pittsburgh and i think they would
love the chance to do it before they get
there though they have a winning end
game against the baltimore against the
cincinnati bengals and they had that
three years ago
week 17 and andy dalton got them on a
fourth and 12 49 yard touchdown pass to
tyler boyd with 44 seconds left and
remember the bills fans contribute to
andy dalton's foundation because it
opened the door for the first bill's
playoff birth since 1999.
the ravens lost in that setting and john
harbaugh told me after the game
yesterday he's he's going to allude to
that game since they played the bengals
again
but but he's not going to harp on it too
much because he doesn't want the guys to
get tight and they're very loose right
now they're confident right now they've
won four games in a row and they've won
playoff style games against teams that
needed to win they they beat the giants
yesterday in a game the giants needed to
win so the ravens are in postseason form
and uh they're going to be ready i agree
with you chris to create some problems
when january rolls around i i think so
you know they're they're they're that
team that and i don't think we expected
to be talking about it with them but
you've hit on this scenario a lot
they're that team who's kind of been
playing playoff football for the last
four weeks and then you just go uh oh
here we go you know now they're in a
must-win situation for the last game of
the year okay so it's important they're
playing another playoff football game
and it's against a lesser team to where
you go they should win that football
game and they should win it you know
pretty comfortably to where they can go
into the playoffs going our chests are
out we feel good it doesn't matter who
you are we think we got a chance to beat
you and i think they should be justified
and you know having those thoughts and
feelings with the way they're playing
right now next one for me is the tanked
for treasure trevor award not tank but
tank we'll call it past tense because
that's what i believe
the jaguars did and we have seen it
before every once in a while
you'll get a proclamation that there's
never tanking there is tanking the
buccaneers did it in 2014 in week 17
they removed their starters most of
their starters so they would blow an
11-point lead to the saints and nail
down the james winston pick
i i
i i think that the choice to go with
mike glennon over gardner minshew the
decision to not play james robinson a
highly effective rookie who has played
through a lot of bumps and bruises this
year i think that the jaguars wanted
nothing to do with potentially winning
on sunday and blowing their shot at a
franchise transforming quarterback
prospect
you're already
one and thirteen who cares if you're one
in fourteen
mission accomplished they'll never admit
it
i don't know what promises may have been
made maybe doug marone gets one more
year with trevor lawrence maybe that's
maybe that's the quid pro quo for him to
go along with the tank scenario where
they
let glennon play instead of minshew who
in their right mind would say that mike
glennon's a better quarterback than
gardner minshew chris not that mitchu
has lived up to the potential we saw
last year why not go from glenn and
dementia at some point yesterday when
it's starting to fall apart i just think
and i'll have a problem with it no
problem with it
they're going to be far better off with
trevor lawrence but but mission
accomplished for the jacksonville
jaguars they're going to have trevor
lawrence and if trevor lawrence is as
good as advertised the teams in the afc
south are going to have to deal with
this guy for the next 10 years or longer
yeah no definitely i mean i would i you
know i look at trevor lawrence and i
think um a lot of like it's this is
justin herbert it's a very similar guy
to me in a lot of ways except this is a
guy who you know probably even a little
more athletic than justin herbert in
some ways i don't know if he can throw
it the same way herbert's pretty special
throwing the football but it's that type
of guy where you just look at him and i
think we're gonna all look at him and
just go just like justin herbert we saw
one game we were like this guy belongs
and then we saw two games you were like
this guy's really good and then we saw
three games and we went holy crap he's a
superstar and that's what i think we'll
see with demarcus i mean with dexter
lawrence when he when he gets trevor
lawrence excuse me all these damn
lawrences uh yes i do think we'll see
that and you know i'm i'm with you kudos
to jacksonville getting it done
with you know getting it done the way
they wanted to get it done and doug
marone with jay gruden that's a pretty
good good damn combination to you know
bring in a young quarterback with guys
who have been there done that and have a
pretty good track record i mean doug
marone did go to the playoffs with a
rookie quarterback and got to the final
four and his name was blake bortles jay
gruden's been around the block he knows
how to do that too so i don't think
that's the worst idea you've ever thrown
out there certainly not you know
speaking of quarterbacks i'm going to
the mariano rivera award because i've
never seen anything like this you know
the miami dolphins on sunday saturday i
mean that just
have you ever seen where it's just like
hey we're going to pull the starter and
throw the backup in and nobody's going
to really care and we're not going to
drop in fact we're actually more
dangerous and better when we throw in
the backup than we do with the
quarterback the starter you know
it's amazing what we're seeing with the
miami dolphins that whole game was
amazing the amazing at the the you know
finale everything like that but i think
just the the scenario again for the
second time this year where we see tua
look there
and really make no plays or nothing that
makes you go ooh i really wow this is
awesome
and get pulled out of a football game
and ryan fitzpatrick came in comes in
just like he did in denver and the team
just marches up and down the football
field that's got to be a little
concerning to miami either way but
either way i've never seen a team handle
it as well as they do that's that's what
i'm really surprised by
it's a testament to brian flores he's
able to create the the mood and the
atmosphere in the locker room where no
one is upset and if they are right
they're not saying anything to anyone
about it because if they do they're
gonna have to answer to brian flores and
secondly it's a testament to the
character of tuatanga vialoa that he's
not upset about it that he's not
selfish that he understands there's a
reason for it and he understands that
every once in a while the team needs the
spark that ryan fitzpatrick can provide
and fits too it's
it's that's right because fitz isn't
clamoring right to be the starter and he
very well could be it wouldn't be hard
to do it you get the word out you talk
to some people off the record you get
your agent pumping him up hey i can't
believe that flores is doing this no
fitzpatrick is fine with his role tua is
fine with his role and uh
and and and it's working but the thing
is it doesn't feel sustainable no it's
because we've never seen it
be sustained ken wisdom hunt tried it in
2007 with matt leinart and kurt warner
and when they'd fall behind he'd pull
liner and he put in warner and then when
warner would would save their bacon
they'd put liner back in and it was
lather rinse repeat until liner suffered
a broken collarbone and then warner
became the starter until he retired
after the 2009 season
it just doesn't feel like something that
will work and chris i tweeted this on
saturday night after the dolphins won
and i don't expect
dolphins fans in their euphoria to agree
with me
but the one thing that would nag at me
if i was a dolphins fan
is they picked
two when they should have taken justin
herbert
that you wouldn't have to bench justin
herbert you'd be better off with justin
herbert if you were oh oh herbert's got
better weapons server's got no look i
think what we've seen so far
and tua may
may have a much better career he may win
more more games get into the playoffs
more often win a championship who knows
but
i think objectively we can say based on
what we've seen so far herbert's the
better quarterback right yeah i mean
herbert herbert is getting into the
like no doubt top ten quarterback
conversation
he is
in the conversation of one of the five
best throwers in football already
there's no area that tua has an
advantage over justin herbert i'm not
trying to be a jerk or a smart ass or
anything like that that's just the fact
of the matter there you go through the
checklist herbert wins
herbert has been special all year long
and he makes game-changing throws he has
won them football games and he has been
the reason they've been in games to
where they can find a way to lose them
at the end but probably aren't in those
games unless it's a guy like justin
herbert who can just make throws that
are off the charts good so
yes they should be kicking themselves so
mike i i've even talked about this a
little bit on my my podcast last week
and everything too this is where we got
to be careful about letting fan bases
run the team and tell us who should be
the quarterback i don't know how good
would the dolphins be if they still had
ryan tannehill and then use the number
five pick on something else or maybe
traded down and got other players
man how good would they be but instead
the narrative in miami was tannen hills
crap and we're gonna blame him for
everything so uh i hear what you're
saying but uh yes uh clearly herbert's
special there to a great
like leader charisma the ability to
handle the situation all that managing
games to where he's not messing it up
but what we're seeing right now is yeah
he doesn't lose you games but he doesn't
necessarily win you games that's kind of
where he is right now in his development
and as you said it's very early so let's
not you know jump the shark uh too quick
and and i think brian flores is still
trying to figure out the best way to
handle this situation too on the fly on
saturday night he characterized ryan
fitzpatrick as our relief pitcher on
sunday when flores met with reporters he
said i don't want to apply labels to
anyone so
i
yeah look this is new for him and for
all of us and and when you see ryan
fitzpatrick make the throw that he made
with his head
being twisted around a la linda blair in
the exorcist
and he makes that throw and sets up the
game-winning field goal
i think you have a quicker trigger
finger the next time around if the
offense is struggling and you're going
to here let's let's play it out because
because i i wish i had tweeted this on
saturday night because then i could
point to it as proof my son and i were
watching the game
and i said to him when tool was
struggling in the second half
man you know i
wonder if they're going to bring in ryan
fitzpatrick i said ah dismiss it it's
the offensive the offensive line is
terrible it's not going to matter next
drive here came fitzpatrick but you're
going to have guys on the sideline now
kind of looking around a little bit more
if the dolphins are struggling because
they know what fitzpatrick can do the
more that you pull the rabbit out of the
hat
the more that the people around the
magician are going to want to see him go
out there and do his trick that that's
that's human nature that's the problem
and if they start struggling against
buffalo in a must-win game that's
playing out when all these other games
that are interconnected are playing out
you're gonna have guys on that sideline
who are clamoring for ryan fitzpatrick
but they're gonna they're gonna have
that this week not that they're gonna be
clamoring but there's gonna be people in
miami in that locker room this week
going
hey like i like tua but why are we still
starting him
why are we doing this i don't i don't
understand it you know again let's not
forget there was no reason to bench ryan
fitzpatrick to start with i mean he was
playing pretty good football but i i do
think with that you know when you go
through
a game in three quarters
and then some guy comes in in one
quarter and doubles your output as far
as throwing the football and then of
course just to your eye you just go the
offense looks different
you know that's where you're you're
gonna have people talking quietly in the
corner of the locker room going
fitzpatrick looks better why don't we
just run with him and two will be here
for a while and we we don't have to
force this right now i think that's
going to be a conversation now to like
you said flores has done a great job of
handling this whole situation and they
have two quarterbacks that really know
how to handle it and are very mature
about it as well but how can you not
have you know some of those thoughts if
you're in that locker room right now uh
and i'll be interested to watch that
film and see if tua
left something on the field that was
there to be had uh
uh in the game too and just did he leave
some big plays out there on the field
and as we go to break one final thought
that just kind of crystallizes we're
considering this the thing about
fitzpatrick in recent years has been
that that switch toggles back and forth
from fits magic to fitz tragic and when
you finally buy in
that's when it falls apart right
flores is i think trying to master
using fitzpatrick in just enough doses
right that it never turns fits tragic so
just you capture the fit's magic and
then you put it back on the shelf and
then you bring it back out and it's
magic and you put it back on the shelf
and if you overuse it right it goes bad
it goes sour like milk that sat out on a
sunny on a sunny uh a window ledge so
i think there's some of that psychology
going into this as well because we've
seen it time and again it eventually
wears off it eventually runs out he
eventually does something that he
shouldn't have done and you say why the
hell is this guy in there
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports